Here are 6 ways to start a sentence.
1. The subject.
One of the best ways to start a sentence is to put the subject first and the verb second.
The subject of a sentence is the person, place, thing or idea.
It has to be followed by a verb,...
...a word that tells you what the subject is doing.
I cooked spaghetti.
The dog ran home.
John read a book.
2. Explaining where or when something happens.
You can start a sentence with words that tell you where something is happening.
On the beach, there was a shipwreck...
...or it could be beside the beach,...
...by the beach,...
...near the beach.
You can also start a sentence with words that tell you when something is happening.
After school, we played computer games or it could be before school.
Don't forget to use a comma.
3. Asking a question.
Have you ever thought of starting a sentence with a question?
A question makes the reader think.
Which songs do you like best?
Who is the richest person in the world?
Make sure you answer your question in the next sentence.
Have you brushed your teeth today?
Forgetting to brush your teeth leads to bad breath and tooth decay.